today is the deadline for high school
seniors to tell colleges where they
intend to enroll in August for most
students how to pay for school is a
major consideration student loan debt is
a one and a half trillion dollar
financial crisis in America the average
household with student debt owes more
than $47,000 mark Strassmann examines
the issue in a special CBS News series
life and debt mark good to have you here
good to be here good morning it's let me
show you one measure of the price tag
america's student loan debt is greater
than car loan debt and credit card debt
college has become wildly expensive for
most families and yet colleges one
instance may be the only one when banks
will consider a teenager with no credit
history no guaranteed income and a loan
that can run into the hundreds of
thousands of dollars the most expensive
piece of paper Ione College changed
Taylor Smith's life for the better
college debt changed it for the worse
now 25 this sales rep for a Houston tech
company feels pressured by loans she
started taking out as a college-bound
high school senior you were 18 people
were loaning you tens of thousands of
dollars yeah exactly and nobody's
talking to you about it either when
Smith graduated from Texas A&M she owed
fifty three thousand dollars in student
loans she had to quit her first job
registering voters in Colorado it didn't
pay enough I sacrificed the dream job to
come home so I could take care of my
bills that was a big reality check
realizing like this bill that I have is
what's gonna hold me back forty three
million Americans currently have student
debt on average they owe more than 47
thousand dollars 5.2 million are in
default and college costs keep rising
for example at Ohio State a public
university in state students pay around
$27,000 a year an elite private school
like Stanford costs about 74 thousand
dollars when you get that that letter it
is am I going to school or not and if
I'm going to go to school I will need to
take on more debt than I could possibly
fathom
Seth frat Mons the executive director of
the student borrower Protection Center a
non-profit watchdog is student loan debt
America's new financial crisis I think
the student debt crisis is here with no
end or change in sight and absolutely
zero plan to tackle this at the federal
level and the crisis is
multi-generational have a seed Seraphina
Galante is 76 this career social worker
got her master's degree in her 50s she
graduated with about $35,000 in debt and
owes more than that 19 years later
$38,000 partly because she can't even
afford to pay the total interest every
month I was one of the oldest students
senior borrowers like her are the
fastest growing group of the student
debt crisis it's not going to reduce
ever and the emotional part of it that
it's there that it's always going to be
there
Seraphina Galante told us she will die
owing money to her college loan lenders
while Taylor Smith has put off getting
married starting a family buying a home
until she has these loans paid off
Rodman says policymakers about the
federal and state level need to address
this crisis and he says they have simply
failed millions of Americans taking on a
debt to pursue a better life it's just I
opening how many families are in this
impossible position they want to do
right by their kids send them to the
school of their dreams but can't afford
it right we're sending you out into the
world with a huge lead coat on you I
mean it's well that's the thing too is
that these these schools educate kids
and say go pursue your dreams chase your
dreams they can't afford to chase their
dreams because they have this monthly
payment that they have to serve right
and there's no financial education that
goes along with that degree to say
here's how you handle it when you can
click a to this University what eight
year-old is financially sophisticated I
know I was nobody yeah you have nobody
and then they get a job that they have
to take a job they don't want that
because the one that they want doesn't
pay them there has to be a better way to
do this mark yeah that's what do you got
on that
all right thank you mark you